this video was made possible by
curiositystream
if you've already signed up for the
curiosity stream nebula bundle deal make
sure to watch the extended cut of this
video on nebula
if you haven't signed up yet you can get
both curiosity stream
and nebula bundled together for just 15
a year with the current sale
at curiositystream.com wendover
china has backed itself into a corner
about a year ago in spring 2020 it
emerged
triumphant after months of devastation
it became the first country to
coax life back to near normal after a
widespread
covid epidemic just as it emerged from
lockdown
the rest of the world was entering into
it so china started to focus its
attention
on not only recovering from kovid but
also from the hit it took to its global
image as a result of perceived
mismanagement in the virus's early days
as the us and europe struggled from far
larger far more devastating outbreaks
china sat on the sidelines working on
ways to be viewed
not only as the country that crushed
kovid within its borders
but also led the fight against it around
the world
they wanted to be seen doing what the
u.s and europe couldn't
while they were focused on their
problems at home as hospital ships
docked and intensive care units
ballooned in size throughout april and
new york
planes were landing at jfk carrying
thousands of desperately needed
ventilators from china
as hospitals around the world ran out of
supplies and required healthcare workers
to reuse masks for days or weeks on end
national airlines were making special
dedicated trips to pick up medical
supplies donated by china
as every corner of the world worked to
ramp up testing to get a more accurate
picture of their problems
chinese-made test kits were streaming
through their borders
china was at the center of the fight
against the virus
but the center can be the riskiest place
to be
as donations turned into purchases it
emerged that there was a major
quality problem some 90 of mask
certifications from china
according to one measure were fake tests
that were supposed to have 80
sensitivity actually had 30 percent and
stories emerged
globally of chinese officials demanding
public displays of thanks in exchange
for donations
what was supposed to be a diplomacy coup
rekindled an old narrative
of chinese made as inferior at best
this effort did little to rewrite
china's role in the pandemic
but at worst it seems very possible that
it actually
further damaged their global image
however
while the start and the middle of the
pandemic did not entirely go china's way
in terms of global image there was still
the end china still had the chance to
recover what they'd lost
and more specifically they had the
chance to display their homegrown
scientific skill
and manufacturing might china could be
the country that supplies the shots that
would end the world's misery
and put the pandemic in the history
books they
could make the world's vaccine but of
course
first they needed a vaccine
luckily they had a head start as soon as
the outbreak began in china
a number of private companies
state-owned enterprises and
government-run institutes
started work on developing a vaccine by
spring
there were some strong viable candidates
so the next step
was testing just as most of the western
world entered their lockdowns
the first chinese vaccine 85-nco-v
by cannes sinobiologics entered a phase
1 clinical trial
on march 17 2020 with 108 adults in
wuhan receiving the shot
after positive data this same vaccine
became the first
in the world to enter phase 2 trials on
april 11th
with 508 participants when the results
from that trial were published on july
20th
they revealed that not only was the
vaccine acceptably safe
but that it was also generating the
desired immune response
in short it was seemingly both safe and
effective
however the next phase of clinical
testing presented a problem
for cannes sino you see phase 1 vaccine
trials are about seeing if they're safe
and then phase 2 trials are about seeing
if they generate the desired immune
response in the body
phase 3 trials however that's about
seeing if the vaccine works
in the real world to see if it actually
protects
humans to do so researchers divide the
study participants
into two equal sized groups one receives
the
actual candidate vaccine the other
receives a placebo shot
typically just a saline solution then
the two groups are tracked to see
if one is less likely to contract the
virus than the other
the problem for cannes sino the other
chinese vaccine makers and the country
at a whole
was that by late summer when the first
chinese vaccines were moving into phase
3 trials daily coveted cases in the
country
had been reduced to double-digit levels
in a country of well over
a billion most phase 3 vaccine trials
have below 50 000 participants
so it would take years if not decades at
those caseloads to get to the hundreds
of infections needed in a trial to prove
a vaccine's efficacy
essentially it was impossible for
chinese companies to complete their
coveted vaccines in china
exactly because the country had done so
well as suppressing the virus
therefore they had to move abroad
the cannes sino-ad5-n-cov vaccine
started phase 3 trials in russia
pakistan
saudi arabia mexico argentina and chile
while the other leading candidates moved
to dozens of other countries
with more severe covet epidemics however
with many of these china and its
pharmaceutical companies
had to curry favor with each government
typically that took the form of offering
priority access to the very vaccines
that they were testing
which was fine for the moment as of now
five chinese-made vaccines have been
approved in the country
in general there has been widespread
criticism of the country's vaccine
development practices
they've started vaccinating the general
public before their phase 3 trials
reached their endpoints
they haven't been forthcoming with
clinical trial data they've
misrepresented efficacy ratings from
trials
and more however despite that there is
evidence that these vaccines are
acceptably safe
and effective even if potentially less
so than other approved vaccines
on december 30th the bb ibp core v
vaccine manufactured by sinopharm
a chinese state-owned enterprise was
approved in the country
making it one of the first code vaccines
in the world to be deployed in the
general population
despite the fact that this vaccine was
developed and manufactured by a company
owned by the chinese government and
despite the fact that the country had
some 1.4 billion people to inoculate
many of the first doses of the cynofarm
vaccine were sent
beyond their borders chinese state-owned
media reports that the company has
orders for its vaccine
from over 100 countries although the
details of such orders are not publicly
known
leading to some skepticism over the
numbers we do know details for certain
orders though
and in some cases we might know more
than china wants us to
in general though china's goal with its
global vaccine distribution
is essentially to do what it failed to
do with masks
ventilators and tests in 2020. china
wants to be the country
that ended other countries epidemics
now even though western vaccines from
modern and pfizer have a 95
efficacy rating compared to 50 to 83
percent in chinese vaccines
those western vaccines have order
obligations taking up their inventory
into well into 2022 however
that's not the case with certain chinese
vaccines so some countries are making
the calculation
that it's better to have a less
effective vaccine sooner
than the alternative of course for china
this is a major diplomacy coup
countries historically allied with the
west such as hungary and mexico
are turning to china in their narrative
china is doing what the west cannot
of course they want this to continue and
even ramp up
that's why they've been sending their
vaccines all around the world
for free mongolia and sri lanka received
300 000 doses of the cyanofarm vaccine
algeria sierra leone and zimbabwe 200
and belarus equatorial guinea gabon
mozambique namibia and bolivia
100 000. now a couple hundred thousand
doses
isn't going to end any of these
countries epidemics but it's enough for
clips of healthcare workers receiving
chinese-made and donated vaccinations to
make the evening news
it's also enough for each of these
countries to see that these vaccines are
acceptably safe and effective
giving them little reason to not order
more when china is offering them months
or
years before the big western
manufacturers however
the fact that many of china's vaccines
are made and distributed by state-owned
enterprises
has led many to wonder whether the
country is choosing who gets these
life-saving inoculations
based on diplomatic intentions is
leading many to wonder
whether who lives and who dies in this
pandemic
is starting to be based on how friendly
the country on a given person's passport
is to the people's republic of china the
answer to this question
is not hard to find on the readout of
the call between chinese dick counselor
and foreign minister wang yi
an algerian foreign minister sabri
bokudoum the chinese official brought up
algeria's vote 50 years ago to switch
chinese representation at the un from
the republic of china government
now known as taiwan to the people's
republic of china which most now refer
to
as china in addition the chinese
official noted algeria's participation
in china's belt and road infrastructure
development initiative
before announcing the country's
intention to donate two hundred thousand
sino-farm vaccine doses to
algeria elsewhere in south america
10 of its 12 countries have vaccinated
their populations with either purchased
or donated chinese vaccines
the only two exceptions are surinam the
lowest population country on the
continent
and paraguay now paraguay's absence on
the list of countries to have received
chinese vaccines
is not tough to figure out it's because
of another list
that they are on paraguay is one of just
15 countries
worldwide that recognizes taiwan as an
independent
nation something that undermines china's
claims of the islands
in fact there is zero overlap between
the list of countries that recognizes
taiwan
and those that have received chinese
covid vaccines
however the cases of algeria and
paraguay
simply show china rewarding its allies
and ignoring its foes
this is not at all different from how
the u.s for example
has operated so far regarding covet
vaccine donations
it sent them to strong allies like
mexico and canada
although it's quite possible that china
is going beyond rewarding its key
existing allies and using vaccines to
try
and form new ones brazil and the us have
gone along rather well in recent years
especially over most of the past four as
brazilian president jair bolsonaro is an
open admirer of former u.s president
donald trump
that meant that brazil followed the us's
lead in banning the chinese telecom
giant huawei from playing a part in
building out their 5g
cell network infrastructure purportedly
out of security concerns
therefore it was a bit of a surprise
when brazilian communications minister
fabio faria
took a trip to beijing in february and
met with huawei executives
according to faria he quote took
advantage of the trip to ask for
vaccines
which is what everyone is clamoring for
soon after
he posted a letter on twitter from the
chinese ambassador to brazil
which noted the request reading quote
during your visit to china
you expressed the desire to continue to
strengthen cooperation between our two
countries regarding covet 19 vaccines
i give this matter great importance
a few weeks later the brazilian
government announced the rules and
structure for its 5g
auction and in a change of course huawei
was now
allowed to participate the company in
response to questions about this
didn't even directly deny that a
tit-for-tat deal took place
in a statement they said that while they
could not directly provide vaccines
they could facilitate quote
communication in an open and transparent
manner in a topic involving the two
governments
well there's no direct evidence of china
trading vaccines for its foreign policy
goals
people are starting to pay more
attention to situations like this
where countries are opening the door for
such an action and china's
certainly not closing that door while
its exact details might still be murky
it is clear that china is engaging in
some form
of vaccine diplomacy this however
presents a problem you see one of the
main advantages of mrna vaccine
technology
the kind used in modern and physical
vaccines
is that it's relatively easy to
manufacture
most other types of vaccines include an
attenuated or dead version of the virus
itself or a portion of it
but growing and then processing the
virus itself is a time-consuming process
that is harder to scale
meanwhile mrna vaccines simply include
the genetic instructions for the body to
create a harmless version of the
chronovirus's spike protein
which can train the immune system to
respond to it done right
that means that mrna vaccine production
can be faster than that of attenuated or
inactivated virus
protein based or viral vector vaccines
the technologies that china's vaccines
are based on
that means that after a slow to scale
manufacturing process
priority order obligations to trial
hosting countries a robust program of
vaccine diplomacy
and an insistence to only use
chinese-made vaccines
that doesn't leave a whole lot of
chinese code vaccines
for china to use for itself as of march
china has administered about five doses
for every 100 citizens
that's compared to between 10 and 15 for
every 100 in most eu countries
35 for 100 in the us and 42 for 100 in
the uk
of course with very few coveted cases
within its borders
there is less of a pressing need for
vaccination in china
but the country's entire foreign image
goal during the pandemic
has been to be viewed as better than
europe or the us
it's to be viewed as the country that
thanks to its remarkable economic
transformation
over the past few decades has caught up
to europe or the us's super power status
at present estimates believe that china
will attain widespread vaccination
towards the end
of 2022 roughly the same
time period as india iran egypt ethiopia
or colombia
by that time assuming all goes to plan
most of the western world will have been
back to normal for at least
a year as the era of border restrictions
snap lockdowns
and economic uncertainty drags on in the
people's republic
that's not the look the country wants
both at home
and abroad now none of this is to say
that china's vaccination practices
necessarily
are or are not immoral or harmful or any
other value judgment
but it is to say that the practices are
problematic for china
itself people both within the country's
borders and beyond
are going to wonder why doses are going
to foreign arms first
when chinese citizens are still
vulnerable they're going to wonder why
china didn't use its newfound wealth to
purchase more effective and faster
delivering vaccines from foreign
manufacturers
they're going to wonder why when life is
back to normal in the west
the country that flouts itself as the
conqueror of the coronavirus
is still far from heard immunity this
wonder
will lead to conclusions and without the
narrative control that they so
desperately work to maintain
china's foreign and domestic image might
once again
suffer in what is hopefully kovan
nineteen's
third and final act
so 15 is about what it costs to get a
fancy burger
a movie ticket or a cocktail at a nice
bar but it's also what it costs to get
a year's worth of access to both
curiosity stream and nebula with the
current sale going on at
curiositystream.com wendover
with that you can watch any one of the
thousands of top quality documentaries
or non-fiction shows on curiosity stream
such as hot roads which is about five
for the world's most dangerous roads and
who uses them
you could also watch all wendover and
hai videos early and ad free
and about once a month like with this
video we published extended cuts to our
normal videos with everything we had to
cut for time on youtube
in addition nebula gives us the funding
to make bigger budget
and more unique content that just
wouldn't work on youtube which we call
nebula originals
and very soon we're going to release a
brand new one
the first documentary filmed on location
that we'll have released
in almost a year rather unbelievably all
of this can be had for just fifteen
dollars a year
with the current sale only if you go to
curiositystream.comwendover
even better that fifteen dollars goes to
help independent creators like us stay
independent
and helps fund the great nebula
originals from us and others
that many of you have come to enjoy so
head to curiositystream.comwendover and
get the bundle deal at its current sale
price
of just 15 a year